The joe rogan experience buddy don't as a motherfucker and go on stay red ban.
You Miss Friday night.
I know I heard about this Friday night how I fucking almost had a nervous
breakdown the time.
Did he tell you,
remember when you and your wife were asking me questions and I was fidgety?
I was having a nervous breakdown.
Right?
You think I'm fucking with you guys though?
I don't know me Friday night I bombed so hard last week.
You know sometimes you get in a transition period,
you've got all of these bits that aren't ready and you bring them up and it's
like you got three of them so you bomb for two weeks,
but all of a sudden one night they all come together.
Now you become a force.
Now it's a different game.
I was in that process for like two weeks.
I was in limbo.
I had good sets in Boston,
but anything I tried out of the ordinary and Boston wasn't clicking for him.
So I just stuck to the fucking original.
And then I came back to the comedy store.
I ate shit somewhere on Monday night and I went to the economy's struck
Thursday.
They opened up with that suicide joke that didn't take me very far
and then the second time I told him the story about my friend who tried to
commit suicide.
She failed and she went up to the comedy store and she bought a gram of coke
from chewy and as we were doing it I said,
you know,
how did you get out of the crazy house?
Then you try to kill yourself three days ago and there was a big Graham,
it was one big line.
She did the whole thing.
She looked at me and she goes,
I ain't crazy.
They let me out.
That was it.
I told that story that we've got some last minute,
one of them near in the rate and the main home and I just died.
I had a fall delete.
I just died.
I just died a slow death that was trying new stuff.
I wasn't going nowhere.
I wanted to talk about Trump and I just died.
So Friday I went to the store and I swear to God guys,
I didn't eat nothing on that.
Smoked some pot I worked at,
I went to the y,
I did chest and the other thing I smoked though before I left the house.
It was a little Brownie.
Let's 70 milligram brownies.
I have like maybe 13 cops left for the day.
I was fucking starving.
This little bong is right there.
It was a half a pack of an antiquey edible.
They give you two brownies each.
Each at each Brownie is 70 milligrams.
That's so crazy scary.
I rub my balls are 70 milligrams.
You understand me?
70 milligrams for uncle Joey is like an APP,
but that's not going to parrot teeth.
It's not even a fuck you're supplying to the rest of the world.
70 milligrams of put you into a fucking hole.
You know,
I gave him a 500 last night.
We split,
we split a
thousand milligram edible roll chain song down at the hall.
Oh my God.
Listen to me.
We split it at three o'clock in the afternoon.
Oh my God.
What are you trying to prove by seven o'clock I was so fucked by eight o'clock
and you know,
usually when you eat your tame animal,
fuck no,
this turned on me.
This animal turn dog.
Sad Bitch beat me at the submissions.
At one point I had the cheese doodles.
That belongs to the baby pirate's booty.
Yeah.
They were on the floor and they were just coming out of my face.
I was just stuffing,
I was just stuffing pirate's booty in my face and a path.
There was a bunch of fruit and pirate's booty.
I couldn't stop.
I kept eating peaches and pirate's booty,
pirate's booty,
cantaloupe and pirate's booty.
I must've ate the whole baby.
My wife was like,
oh.
Cause I had my back turned to them so they couldn't see me.
My wife's like,
what the fuck are you doing it?
Then I go,
listen,
I got to go to this bed.
She goes,
go to bed already.
I went to 45 I slept off four I got up.
I didn't know where.
I was just laying at the 30 minutes like Mad Max.
I just laid,
they'll come see you.
See for killing four in the morning and didn't know where you were.
So low 30 I woke up with a ton of energy,
energy.
I wanted to shower.
I washed the car,
I went for breakfast.
I want to wash the car,
and my wife had the upper bunk.
I taught stage God.
Oh my God.
I was fucked up and I kept calling me and saying,
elite,
if the cops coy don't answer the phone.
He goes,
well,
I haven't cops on the corner.
I got,
I don't know,
but they'll answer.
So funny.
I just had it happen to you again though.
You ate too much at the comedy,
but last night,
no,
last night I didn't have anxiety guys.
Just what I'm saying.
Thi 70 milligrams ain't Dick and my world.
Okay,
so I eat the sudden milligrams.
I go down to Laurel Canyon.
I hooked the right.
I go to the comedy store.
I pulled up no drama.
I get in Joe's upstairs.
I don't even go upstairs because I know the room was packed.
I can't go upstairs,
so I'm alone at the comedy store.
I went to the original image path.
I walk around with it,
but I go into the VIP patio and I just sit there some to,
to listen to music.
Some black dude was smoking a joint.
I mind my business.
I look straight ahead.
I'm thinking about more material.
I'm going to say how I bombed.
It's just whipping me now,
right?
And I'm starting to get scared.
I'm like,
I really don't want to go on stage.
Jeff comes over to me and he goes,
Joey,
go on stage.
I walk over and say,
walk up the stairs.
It's a soul.room.
Megan Mooney,
Morgan Morgan,
Morgan Murphys up on stage.
Fucking fucking,
I don't know what her fucking name.
She had a hat on and she was,
and she was texting her right now.
She was fucking killing,
right?
She's killing Megan.
Move from whatever fucking name is Murphy.
He brought the dog up.
She was freaking me out and then she's killing on stage.
I walk up to the first landing guys and it hits me.
It's like,
oh my God,
I'm getting anxiety attack.
I'm 70 milligrams.
Not,
not,
this can't be happening to me.
This ain't happening.
And all the sudden I'm standing there and it's getting worse.
Guys,
it's getting worse now there's one seat open at the whole comedy store,
this Mitsis jet.
So I sit in there for about a minute.
She's got the blue light on,
the pressure's on,
I got water in my hand,
I get back up and it's getting worse.
Guys.
I turned around,
I looked down to where the phone used to be and now I'm getting the anxiety I
get when I'm getting the needle,
which means I'm going down.
That's I gotta look for day light or air.
I know this like I look for air,
but I know if I go down those stairs,
if she calls my name and I come back up those stairs,
I'm really going to have an anxiety attack.
So I go to the corner and I just started looking at the wall and I start
breathing through my nose and some guy comes up to me,
said,
hey Joey,
how are you doing man?
What's going on?
I go,
not that I keep looking at the wall.
He now he gets to have to walk away.
Then some other guy pops out and he's like,
Hey Joey,
I'm French is such and such.
He goes,
do you know where he is?
I don't give a fuck.
Why don't you see me staring at a fuck?
Don't walk the back.
Jeff comes up to me and I go,
Jeff,
hold on one second.
General,
I'm going to faint.
I got a really bad anxiety attack.
I'm going down here.
Tell Pauli to go on stage.
And Jeff also wants to ask me questions.
He's like,
dude,
do you know if Paul,
he's going to go up on stage.
I don't give a fuck.
He's the closest person in stage.
She's about to call my name.
And all of a sudden he goes,
well,
let me go ask.
I'm gonna fucking go ask him the fuck.
I'm about to fucking faint now.
You gotta do this to me.
So he walks out with a ball and he starts asking Paul and Paul,
he's like,
and now they're getting into like a conversation about it instead of polygon.
He's got an anxiety attack.
Let me go up there.
I'm watching this go down.
I get so angry.
I go fucking guys on the hill.
What did Paul say?
Who the fuck knows what he said,
but instead of going to
go up red bank,
go up,
go up red band.
I got up my anxiety.
You Go,
okay Joey and I'll worry about you later.
You okay?
Yeah.
Just go.
No.
These guys have the conversation.
Bureaucracy.
I got so fucking language.
Did I go?
Fuck you guys.
I'm going to go up and I want update Joe Rogan to set up my life off of fear for
you.
I think I caught myself at the 14 minute mark.
I just yell.
Did you record it?
No.
Why would I do something like that?
You don't have a fucking retard.
I fucked that one up there and his joy low.
You know you'll never hear me talking like this.
It was,
yeah.
Oh,
I'm fear and I remember walking out of there,
man,
I got in that car and Paul,
he goes,
man,
you shouldn't have anxiety attacks more often than,
and I was like,
I was fucking dying.
Oh,
okay.
You have Mitsis voice when you do the impression appalling.
The same say Boise.
Do when you do Mitzi?
Like all this shores share one Joey Diaz voice.
Okay.